foreign
hey what's going on good people of the
internet I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report direct message and today
is Monday July 12 20
21. uh as a reminder do me a favor
subscribe to our YouTube channel tap
that notification Bell share these
videos yada yada yada all right we got
four stories for you there is a ton
going on in the world you know I try not
to tweet on the weekends I play around
in the locals community and I share some
food and that kind of stuff but I
usually shut it down on the weekend so I
not paying that much attention to
current events and everything else
although people are always texting me
about things and everything so it's hard
to really Escape which is why I do that
whole August Off the Grid thing but a
lot happened over the weekend so we got
four stories for you today first uh
Kamala Harris you know this woman she's
that like psychotically cackling vice
president uh well she had a did an
interview where she's basically now
saying that rural people people who live
in the middle of the country that they
can't find photocopy machines for their
IDs so that's why we shouldn't have
voter ID laws these are the same people
she is the same woman who will tell you
that black people in inner cities can't
get IDs so if you're black in an inner
city you can't get an ID and basically
when they say rural they mean white if
you're white and then the middle of the
country you can't photocopy your ID I
mean the soft bigotry of low
expectations truly knows no bottom to
this pit so we're gonna hit that then of
course the big story of the day is that
there are massive massive
anti-government anti-communist protests
in Cuba it's quite extraordinary we've
got some video and of course we've got
some reaction not only from our
wonderful mainstream media here in the
United States but you'll see the stark
contrast in responses by some
conservative leaders and some Lefty
leaders here in America and sadly it
will not surprise you the third story uh
yeah the White House is now officially
promoting systemic racism we know that
they've been pushing it in to the system
already right like even with the covid
relief Bill where if you were a black
farmer you were going to get benefits
about a white farmer didn't get because
I'm pretty sure kovid chose who it was
going to affect based on the color of
skin well now the White House is going
all in so we've got video of everyone's
favorite Jen sucky and finally CNN have
you watched that clown network uh
recently it's it's just terrible you
shouldn't watch it I hope you don't
watch it and if you do watch it I hope
you've got some vodka with you uh well
they are really really uh going all in
on attacking unvaccinated people people
who've made a choice for themselves and
perhaps their their family and loved
ones and they are ramping the scare
tactics up to like level bananas so we
are going to cover all of that before I
get to it I want to talk to you guys
about Bambi you know when running a
business HR issues can kill you wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations the list
goes on and on HR manager's salaries
aren't cheap at an average of 70 000
bucks a year Bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
was created specifically for your small
business you can get a dedicated HR
manager craft HR policy and maintain
your compliance all for just 99 a month
with Bambi you can transform HR from
your biggest liability to your greatest
strength your dedicated HR manager is
available by phone email or real-time
chat from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day-to-day all for just 99 a
month month to month no hidden fees
cancel any time if you're like me then I
bet you didn't start your business
because you wanted to spend all of your
time on HR compliance ain't that the
truth let Bambi help get your free HR
audit today uh go to bambi.com Reuben
right now to schedule your free HR audit
that's bambi.com Reuben spelled bam to
the bee.com slash Reuben and now back to
me okay so we've got some video CEO of
Kamala Harris now this is the cackling
woman who is polling at zero in her own
presidential Party primary when she
bowed out of the race and then Joe Biden
or whoever's pulling Joe Biden strings
chose her as the vice president and if
you want to see what the soft bigotry of
low expectations is here is exhibit a is
agreeing to voter ID one of those
compromises that you'd support I don't
think that we should
underestimate what
that could mean
because in some people's mind that means
well you're going to have to
um Xerox or or photocopy your ID to send
it in to prove you are who you are well
there are a whole lot of people
especially people who live in rural
communities who don't there's no Kinkos
there's no Office Max near them people
have to understand that when we're
talking about voter ID laws
be clear about who you have in mind and
what would be required of them to prove
who they are
of course people have to prove who they
are
but not in a way that makes it them
almost impossible for them to prove who
they are
God these people never stop lying they
are gaslighting all of America let's get
that exact quote there at the end of
course they have to prove who they are
but not in a way that makes it almost
impossible to prove who they are and
then her argument is that if you live in
the rural area let's say you live in
Montana or Idaho there's no Kinkos near
you there's no Staples you would be
unable to get to a photocopy machine to
prove that your ID is yours and
photocopy it then send it to the proper
authorities to vote she then says I
don't think we should underestimate what
that would mean meaning voter ID laws
that you'd have to prove who you are we
shouldn't underestimate what that would
mean that in my humble opinion that
would mean you as a citizen would have
to show an ID prove who you are and then
you get one vote one vote one person
let's prove who you are Zippity Dippity
right like not that confusing not really
crazy racist right-wing stuff pretty
standard sort of Civil Society 80 you
know kind of 101 we have to have some
rules to make sure that we don't have
voter fraud but the thing is the
Democrats do want voter fraud like what
could possibly be any other conclusion
than listening to that and thinking that
woman wants there to be voter for it
these are the same people who will tell
you I mean Joe Biden has said this
repeatedly that black people don't know
how to get an ID or don't have the
ability to get an ID he also said that
black people don't can have no ability
to get lawyers or accountants and
they're not sure how to get online these
are the non-racists I mean really think
about what's going on here so on one
hand she's telling you that the inner
city people because when they say inner
city they mean black people so inner
city people can't get an ID and Rural
people can't photocopy an ID thus we
should have no ID requirements when you
want to vote this is gobbley [ __ ] that
is designed to make sure that we don't
have any voter ID laws and when she says
it makes it almost most impossible to
prove who they are I really want you to
think about this really think about this
please let me know please join us in our
robust conversations at
reubenreport.locals.com let me know do
you know anyone that if they had to show
an ID or photocopy an ID to vote
that that would be almost impossible
it doesn't exist it doesn't exist and I
hearken back to my interview about a
month and a half ago with former South
Carolina Governor Nikki Haley we did it
right here In This Very Room who when
the Democrats in her state were saying
oh no people can't get IDs what are we
going to do she said okay let's put
money for it let's put money into a
program to ensure that everyone black
white gay straight etc etc can get a
voter ID and you know what happened 12
people took her up on him 12 people in
all of South Carolina so the point is
that when you get on a plane you have to
show an ID when you buy a beer you have
to show an ID as I said last time I went
mini golfing I had to show an ID because
they wanted me to return the golf club
yet for some strange reason I I'll have
to meditate on this the Democrats don't
want you to have IDs and not only do
they not want you to have IDs or not
have to show an ID I guess they want you
to have an ID to get on a plane and get
a beer right like they're not
complaining about that but not want you
to show an idea to vote and there might
be a reason for that and we'll all have
to think about what that reason might be
but these people are just ridiculous
okay let's move on to the to the real
story of the day because this is
absolutely extraordinary and and it's
also
um
I'm feeling very proud of America right
now because the people that we're about
to show you these are pro-american
people you're going to see American
flags and people chanting about freedom
and you know why they're doing that
because Cuba has a Communist Regime okay
and these people want to be free right
they don't want to be under the gun of
the government all the time actually
this past weekend I was in Miami and
Miami obviously has a tremendous amount
of Cuban refugees Cuban immigrants and
ironically yesterday I took a very early
flight it was Sunday morning I took a
very early flight flight from Miami back
here to L.A and I'm in the Uber and the
Uber drivers most of the Uber driver I
can't say most but a huge percentage it
seems like most of the Uber drivers in
Miami are Cuban now that might be for
good reason they come to this country to
find Freedom and then they have to work
jobs not everyone wants to be an Uber
driver but it's a great job to have so
that you can hopefully build a better
life for your family and your children
all that stuff anyway I'm talking to the
Uber driver at like seven in the morning
before these protests were happening as
far as I knew and I I don't think I
don't think they had even started yet
and he was going on and on about how
much he loves America and how much he
supported Trump and how he hates Biden
and a whole bunch of other stuff anyway
then I get off the plane and then I'm
seeing all these videos of what's going
on in Cuba so first we're going to show
you a quick compilation about 40 seconds
of three different videos about what's
happening in Cuba right this very moment
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
okay so there's obviously many many more
videos like that there's tons of videos
with American flags and people chanting
free they want freedom they want Liberty
all of those things it will not surprise
you that so far the message out of our
Administration Joe Biden tweeted
something and then saki said something
that basically these protests are
because of covid lockdowns and and not
being able to get enough vaccines yes I
am not making that up that's what
Biden's tweet basically said it is
complete nonsense that is not why these
people are out on the street that might
be five percent of it that they're not
happy with whatever the Communist Regime
is doing related to lockdowns and
vaccines and everything else these are
people who want to be free you know that
thing that most likely if you're
watching this show that you have that
they don't have in places like Cuba and
places like Venezuela and places like
North Korea that's the thing that they
want the thing that we so take for
granted so of course our Administration
is giving a very confusing and muddled
message because the the administration
in effect because clearly Biden
whoever's running the Biden show saki
all of the Democrats at this point
because they obviously have leanings
that are in kind with the socialists
with the Communists they like that stuff
that's the stuff they're ushering in
here they don't want to come out as
anti-communists right so the messaging
is very confusing these aren't
pro-capitalist or pro-america or
pro-freedom uh rallies these are
actually rallies because of covid
vaccines like it's such extraordinary
nonsense absolutely extraordinary uh so
we've got a couple tweets here we picked
three people uh they happen to all the
Florida people because there are so many
Cuban immigrants in Florida so I thought
this would be interesting so first this
is from Senator Marco Rubio who uh is
his family is from Cuba he often tells
the story of his parents as first
generation immigrants protests in Cuba
isn't simply about shortages socialism
promises guaranteed food medicine and
income if you give up your freedom when
as always it fails to deliver you don't
get get your freedom back that's why
protesters are chancing libertad and
then he has the couple hashtags there
that people are using on Twitter then
from governor of Florida Ron DeSantis
Florida supports the people of Cuba as
they take to the streets against the
tyrannical regime in Havana the Cuban
dictatorship has repressed the people of
Cuba for decades and is now trying to
silence those who have the courage to
speak out against its disastrous
policies
and then finally this is Miami mayor
Francis Suarez who you may remember I
interviewed a few weeks ago in Miami his
father was the mayor of Miami and now
he's the mayor of Miami his father from
Cuba I believe Francis was you know
Francis was I was born in Miami for sure
he said the Cuban regime's military
police are shooting at unarmed Cuban
protesters Fighting For Freedom 60 years
of Communism cruelty and oppression
cannot last any longer we are imploring
the USA to take action as we peacefully
demonstrate on the streets of Miami so
that's some of the messages all three of
them obviously are Republicans from
California as I said because of the
location of South Florida to Cuba there
are a tremendous amount of Cubans in in
Miami and in Florida more broadly and if
you just want to meet a group of people
who love freedom who love America and
all of those things then you should meet
some Cuban Americans because they're a
great example of what the American dream
absolutely is but now I will read some
tweets about what's happening in Cuba
from AOC ilhan Omar and Bernie Sanders
oh wait
there are none
there are zero tweets from AOC ilhan
Omar and Bernie Sanders and a bunch of
the other ones from the Hamas caucus and
the point is and the reason is that
there are no tweets from them as I said
is because they actually support the
regime they want the United States to be
more of a communist socialist
dictatorship they want the government to
have all of the Power so they don't want
to promote anything that might show
people yearning for freedom and yelling
about Liberty and showing the American
flag because it's the antithesis of
everything they believe so really think
about what's going on right now like
again you know as I always talk about we
all have friends that are on the fence
about these things a little bit unclear
about what you know the truth is what
the what the real message of what's
happening in the day is and it's like
this is a pretty great example those
people want freedom who's standing up
for the freedom well I just mentioned
the Florida Senator Marco Rubio the
Florida governor Ron DeSantis and the
Miami mayor Francis Suarez one of them
or two of them happened to be Cuban
originally you know so it's like you see
you see what's happening here and then
nothing nothing from AOC Ohan and Bernie
sort of like the first story meditate on
that I will uh all right let's uh jump
back into America for a moment so you
guys know I love this gen sake this is a
woman who's just her ability to lie it's
like you gotta kind of admire it it's
like wow you say a lot of nothing and
when you do rarely say something it's a
lie and she mumbles and stammers through
almost everything she says uh and now
she's basically admitting that the
United States is going to go all in on
critical race Theory because of systemic
racism here's sake delegates in the
National Education Association they
approved a measure last week calling for
support of quote the implementation of
culturally responsive education critical
race Theory and ethnic studies
curriculum the pre k through 12 and
higher education president is obviously
a big fan of Education First Lady he was
a teacher she's a union teacher I'm
wondering what are the president's
thoughts on anti-racism curriculum in
the classroom well the president
believes that in our history there are
many dark moments and there is not just
slavery and racism in our history there
are systemic racism that is still
impacting society today and he believes
as I believe as a parent of children
that kids should learn about our history
so as a the spouse of an educator and as
somebody who has continues to believe
that children should learn not just the
good but also the challenging in our
history and that's part of what we're
talking about here even as it's become
politically charged
okay Jen you're lying as usual here we
go let me unpack it so first off
nobody's saying we can't teach the dark
moments literally nobody is saying it I
have not heard one person that has any
credibility anywhere saying that we
can't teach about the dark moments of
our history that we're not allowed to
teach about slavery that we're not
allowed to teach about Japanese
internment or any other negative thing
that the United States has done given
given honest assessment of our founding
no one's saying it well you guys are
saying it but nobody else is arguing
that these things should not be taught
and I'm gonna go out on a limb here and
guess that all of you watching this
right now if you went to school in
America whether you went to private
school or public school you learned a
little something about slavery you learn
a little something
about the Civil War the Revolutionary
War you learned a little something about
our history and it didn't just say oh
America is fantastic there was no such
thing as slavery everybody's got a great
note and it's always been that way right
like this is just absolute uh nonsense
then she says kids should learn about
our history yes so we all agree with
that no one's saying that you can't
teach the dark moments and everyone's
saying you should learn about history
but what she's saying is yes we are
going to usher in critical race Theory
and teach everyone about systemic racism
now for the billionth time I know they
love to play semantic games but systemic
racism meaning if there was racism in
the system if there were laws that
favored One race over another that would
be systemic racism and I would be
completely against it okay if you said
oh if you're black you get this and
you're white you get this we got a
systemically racist problem and we got
to get rid of it in the times in America
where there have been things like that
so like Jim Crow laws we have gotten rid
of those things we fought a civil war to
get rid of them Etc et cetera and in
more modern times you know in the 80s in
New York City there were laws that I
think you could argue were systemically
racist for example if you were arrested
for smoking crack which generally was
happening in the inner city by black
people the penalties were higher than
say if you were arrested for snorting
cocaine which was happening down on Wall
Street mostly with white people and
there was a disparity in what was going
on in terms of the sentencing we got rid
of that okay so absolutely we can we can
acknowledge that there have been laws
that have been misguided and all of that
stuff and by the way if you brought
cases forward where there were still
people in jail for X while someone else
was in jail for y when it should have
been similar sentencing and they weren't
we could talk about that oh and there
was a guy
an orange guy what was the orange guy's
name again Trump there was this guy this
orange man named Trump you may remember
him he's not on social media anymore he
was trying to do all of this stuff right
he was trying to do this all with uh
prison reform and he was actually doing
it despite the best efforts and he was
getting the best efforts of the
Democrats and he was getting low level
often marijuana offenders who were
disproportionately black be taken out of
jail that's what he was doing but okay I
know we we don't want to talk about that
but in essence you're saying okay
systemic racism is real now this is not
a phrase that Joe Biden ever said in his
first 47 years of being in public office
that that's a little odd he just
completely forgot to say anything about
it and then Joe Biden was also vice
president under a black president
uh Barack Obama right right and uh
didn't do anything about systemic racism
apparently but now at 78 years old and
potentially with dementia oh and by the
way uh I'm not going to say the Joe
Biden has dementia anymore because you
know I've said it I can't fully diagnose
him with dementia and my sister said to
me you know you say he has dementia and
I usually say I'm not diagnosing him but
it's like you know it's sort of like an
amorphous term like something ain't
right with this guy so I'm gonna say for
now on the Joe Biden has Ops uh this is
old person syndrome I think that would
be a better way of describing what's
going on with Joe Biden he has o p s o
person syndrome so he forgot to tell
Barack Obama about the systemic racism
you know that he was dealing with in
those 47 years uh and then you know
Barack forgot to do anything about it
himself and here we are so these people
are absolutely ridiculous but if you
think that this thing isn't all tied
together and how the unions are involved
and everything else you may remember on
Friday we played this video of Randy
Weingarten who's the president of the
largest teachers union and if you want
to listen to somebody speaking out of
both sides of of their mouth I present
you Randy Weingarten critical race
theory is not taught in elementary
schools or middle schools or high
schools
it's a method of examination
taught in law school and in college that
helps analyze whether systemic racism
exists and in particular whether it has
an effect on Law and public policy
but culture Warriors are labeling any
discussion
of race
racism or discrimination scrt
to try to make it toxic
they are bullying teachers
and trying to stop us
from teaching students accurate history
okay so this woman I mean this is sake
level like so on one hand she's saying
it's not being taught now we know it is
being taught right we've given you
plenty of examples here but just in the
last couple days Chris Ruffo I mentioned
him on the show weekly at this point
who's doing the greatest work when it
comes to exposing this nonsense he found
a list of 30 school districts in America
that are teaching it right now by their
own doctrines right by their own
documents that they use to teach at
least 30 school districts that are now
teaching this stuff in K-12 so on one
hand she's saying it's not being taught
and then if you listen to the last
sentence there she's saying but you know
it is an honest assessment of what's
going on in the world and it's an honest
assessment of our history well if that's
what you believe lady then why wouldn't
you be teaching it so everything that
these people say is just complete
nonsense and as I often say we've got
our work cut out for us let's do one
more for you today CNN
which is a I suppose it's a news network
of some sort it's a it's a fun place run
by democrats like Don Lemon and Chris
Cuomo and Jake Tapper and Wolf Blitzer
and Jim Acosta are any of these people
not obviously Democrats or any of these
people obviously not progressives I mean
they all are but they pretend to be an
unbiased News Network now you might say
Dave but you tell people about the news
you read stories and share your opinion
and yes I do and I think you fairly well
know my opinion and who I voted for and
why I voted and what my biases are and
perhaps what my blind spots might be
this is a wonderful thing that we're
doing here that I think is you know
ballpark honest let's put it that way
right like you know what I you know what
I think I really think you you know as
much about what I think about the world
pretty much as I do I really believe
that because I'm just telling you what I
think here right and then I can you can
match that up with your own reality and
figure out what's what well CNN pretends
that it's a News Network an unbiased
News Network but it's not it's a
propaganda wing of the Democrat Party
and they are really not happy that a
certain amount of Americans are not
getting vaccinated right now again you
make a decision for yourself masks you
know my feelings about all of this stuff
okay and we know again that 97 to 99.5
roughly a percentage of people
who got covid survived kovid the people
who did not survive had comorbidities
diabetes cancer heart disease a series
of other things but they really really
want you to get vaccinated on CNN I'm
not exactly sure why I don't want to be
a conspiracy theorist here but we've got
two videos for you we'll we'll show on
this is Dr Jonathan Reiner on CNN
talking about mandating vaccines
I do think uh it's time to start
mandating uh vaccines and I think that
Private Industry and private
organizations will do that you know at
GW University where I work uh starting
uh this fall you can't be on campus
unless you're fully vaccinated look I
think that we're at in the part of the
pandemic now where the the problem in
this country is that 150 million
Americans are not vaccinated now half of
that uh number is uh less than 18 years
of age but let's look at the adults 75
million adults have chosen not to get
vaccinated and that choice has
consequences now we can't force you to
take a jab in the arm but there are many
jobs perhaps that can prevent you from
working if you decide not to get
vaccinated so I think we need to be more
proactive and I think we will see
industry take the lead in this
oh I mean that should chill it should
send a chill down your spine the
authoritarianism that sits right behind
someone who purports to be a medical
doctor so he's saying 150 million people
aren't vaccinated 75 million of them are
Americans and then basically he's
talking about what the repercussions are
if you don't get vaccinated but notice
he didn't mention the medical
repercussions because he knows if he was
to say what the medical repercussions
are if you don't get vaccinated and by
the way I'm not giving you medical
advice I'm telling you to do what you
think you should do and talk to your
doctor about it and that's what and
that's what you should do right who am I
to telling you what to do and who's this
TV Doctor to tell you what to do but
notice when he says well 75 million
Americans haven't gotten it meaning
million adults now the kids it's
interesting because he's saying 75
million kids have a God he kind of threw
that number away he's coming for the
kids like they're obviously coming to to
have man uh vaccine mandates for the
kids for sure but just dealing with
those Americans notice when he's talking
about the repercussions his
repercussions are you shouldn't be able
to go to work something to that effect
he doesn't say what the repercussions
are if you got Kobe it because if you
got coveted most likely you would then
have the antibodies you would survive
and if you didn't have comorbidities and
you weren't of a certain age and
everything else you would be just fine
after that's the truth that's the truth
but he really really wants you know
where he goes to work at GW they're
going to mandate it and that we should
really encourage other private
businesses because maybe it's
unconstitutional
because of right to privacy and all that
maybe it's unconstitutional for the
government to do it so maybe we should
have private Enterprise do it this by
the way is very similar to when you know
people want Twitter and YouTube and
everybody else the big Tech Guys to
crack down on your speech the government
can't quite do it right you may remember
that moment with AOC at one of the
hearings when she was basically saying
that to Zuckerberg hey we can't do it so
why don't you do it which is the worst
sort of government coercion there is so
these are these are not good people uh
then we've got video more from CNN the
Democratic operatives at CNN this is
former Planned Parenthood president and
current CNN medical contributor lyanna
Wen
for more on vaccines I think this really
depends on what it is that we do at this
point so now we have this Delta variant
that is much more contagious because
it's more contagious it's going to be
even harder for us to reach hard
immunity we're going to have to
vaccinate an even higher proportion of
people to get there what happens then if
we end up having another variant
developing that's even more contagious
that could cause more disease that could
evade the protection of our immune
system and so how quickly we get this
under control and which way we go
depends on what we do now when it comes
to vaccination to overcoming
disinformation and what we really need
to do at this point is to make
vaccination the Easy Choice it needs to
be hard for people to remain
unvaccinated right now it's kind of the
opposite it's fine I mean it's easy if
you're on vaccinated you can do
everything you want to do anyway but at
some point these mandates by workplaces
by schools I think it will be important
to say hey you can opt out but if you
want to opt out you have to sign these
forms you have to get twice weekly
testing basically we need to make make
getting vaccinated the Easy Choice that
is what it's going to take for us to
actually end the pandemic
yeah she's evil can you get me the
numbers on how many uh babies Planned
Parenthood is killed uh last I don't
know give me give me some numbers on
that we'll get some numbers on that in
just a second I say that as someone that
is begrudgingly pro-choice as I
described in my book if you want more of
my feelings on that but she wants to
really make this impossible for you to
make a medical decision for yourself uh
we she then of course brings up the
Delta variant and guess what there's
going to be an Omega variant and there's
going to be another variant after that
and another one after that and
everything else and then we're gonna
have you're gonna have to sign papers
right we're gonna have to show me your
papers you have to sign papers we're
gonna have to perhaps put you in camps
maybe we should give you special showers
uh with certain chemicals in those
showers I mean this all sounds nuts but
we are in a dystopian future and we are
in it right now and it is a Confluence
of our corporate media our completely
psychotic out of control Democrat Party
rid you know which is led by a man with
Ops old person syndrome and then these
these doctors that get get on all of
these shows who clearly got nothing
right if any of these doctors got
anything right in the last year and a
half then wouldn't everything be just
fine right now two weeks to flatten the
curve I mean I say it all the time guys
but we all did it we all did it and we
gave them more than two weeks and we
were all washing our Garb you know our
our bags are when we went to the grocery
stores we all did everything that they
asked everyone did and also
can someone explain to me why one of the
states that opened up didn't collapse
why didn't Florida or Texas or Tennessee
collapse and why wasn't New York or
California or Michigan perfectly
inoculated why are the numbers ballpark
even remotely the same and in most cases
they're better in the red States but if
they did completely different policies
related to all of this why were the
numbers even remotely the same right
none of it makes sense why is it that
not one country somewhere perhaps in
Africa that didn't have the technology
or the wherewithal or the information to
deal with this thing properly why did
not one country fail why didn't we find
one city that was completely infected
and everyone died all of this stuff like
I'm just asking questions here okay I
don't mean to be a crazy right-wing
conspiracy theorist when I say all this
I'm just asking the questions but we
didn't uh let's see
um Planned Parenthood performed 354
000 abortions in 2019 according to live
action what was that it was around it's
around a thousand a day roughly so
that's about a thousand abortions a day
I only bring this up because this woman
is very very concerned about you she ran
Planned Parenthood they did a thousand
abortions a day she's very concerned
about your health uh as for the health
of those babies I guess perhaps not as
much
um all right guys I feel like this was a
chock full of information show for uh
Monday morning in the summer we're we're
rolling right into the summer as I told
you guys last week I have made my plans
for Off the Grid we're actually setting
up a couple shows that we're going to
post in August that are going to all be
about sort of relaxing and getting away
from some of this nonsense and
everything else so we're not going to
bludgeonio with content in August
because I want everybody to kind of calm
down
um if you haven't seen it yet part one
of my interview uh with minority leader
of the House Kevin McCarthy is up right
now and it's a really interesting
interview we did it we did it live in
studio a couple days ago and it's really
really interesting because he's got an
interesting take you know he was sort of
in the Trump Camp then not in the Trump
Camp he's trying to figure out what the
future of the GOP is he he actually
teases some really interesting
interesting information about sort of
the radical wing of the Democrats versus
the old school wing and what really the
inner workings are right there so it's
almost in some ways like there are four
parties in America but we're just
pretending there's two there's sort of
the radical Lefty socialists that have
basically overtaken the Democrats with a
couple moderates there and then what is
the future of the Republican party is it
the Trump party or is it more of the
traditional Republican party and I think
he's one of the guys trying to balance
that thing out figure out what it is you
know I have my feelings on it he has his
all good uh if you want to talk to me
personally people we just found out that
June was our biggest month of growth
ever at reubenreport.locals.com and
there's just tremendous stuff going on
with locals uh right now and I've been
hinting more of it within the community
uh but that's why I was in Miami there's
just a lot of good stuff going on and uh
we will build other people will burn we
will build I hope you will join us in
the building process have a great Monday
everybody we'll see you tomorrow